so yes it's like it's a last session I
know everybody's
interracial so I'll try to keep it
somewhat interesting it will skip
through a few things depending on time
so human ability but first you know
maybe just about my meat so by now most
of you pretty heard I will be a system
so most people you know think about the
large you know submarines and the Jets
and things or the cybersecurity part of
it the company does well most people
don't know is for example you know some
of the stuff that's on the Mars
Curiosity rover comes it comes from us
apparently we build hybrid propulsion
systems for buses and we do a lot of
work with the UK sport especially
leading up to Olympics we behind the
scenes there was a lot of work done
supporting the teams in quite a few
disciplines and that work still ongoing
really really interesting stuff I also
organized the London algorithms and deep
learning meetup where I'm currently well
in steering committee of a new community
were founding which is the UK community
of research software engineers so I also
been for the last couple years me
working as a stem ambassador so doing
lots of outreach working with children
and kids in secondary schools and try to
get them enthused about you know science
technology engineering was currently I'm
working with a local school with two
teams and getting them to build little
underwater robots so really fun stuff
really enjoy I also do a lot of work on
the hacking for humanity or technology
for social good kind of scene so you
know besides the talk if there's
anything you know people do in any of
these areas or interest in please you
know come come talk to me anyway so
human-built e so I'm going to report
here on a project that we did in
collaboration with the University of
Southampton you know I'm just one little
while just one one portion of this a lot
of the heavy lifting here was done by
James machinery as part of his PhD this
was his PhD topic you really went into
the Nitty Gritty build up the models and
everything so when we need with you know
if you have detailed questions about the
modeling but the influence or etc am I
really not the right person to ask for
this is relatively new domain for me but
it looks like I'll be inheriting this
project and take it forward so good
exercise so yeah so the number of people
University of Southampton James
especially so many bae and there's the
main part of this work was published
last year in pervasive mobile
eating and also for this particular bit
of work we built on top of that we've
just submitted a king of paper to kdd so
hopefully that'll get accepted so I'm
just going to talk about the work that
was done here so human mobility all of
us will want walk around with
smartphones or you know we take the tube
or you know there's various ways are our
movements are attract and you know all
there's lots of data out there and you
can make some pretty picture so this is
a taxi right in beijing by somebody
Microsoft Research so mapping all the
pick-up and drop-off points and you know
you can see some patterns and you can
create pretty pictures but yeah there's
some information there closer to home so
I think many of you will probably
already seen this it did the rounds
while ago so this is mapping oyster
oyster cards here in London I see going
through the day in the morning everybody
kind of you know there's this massive
influx of commuters all going towards
London and so ever you ask people go to
work it settles down a bit as you go
towards lunch there's a bit more
movement
and then as you go towards your four
o'clock people start to go home and you
know the sin tMT's again so this is just
tracking oyster oyster data yeah so you
know lots of so you can you know there's
lots of data being collected you can
generate all kinds of very interesting
and pretty pictures and movies and
things but of course what you're
interested in is what can you infer from
the data so if we look at the taxi data
for example again you could look at that
kind of data but as other sources to
look at what are the functional zones in
my city can I discover them from the
date and do they match up with watch
artwork what I'm trying to turn the city
into so does it match with you the
official planning records so you can
look at taxi Rider you look at public
transport uses and various things so you
could say okay you know from that can I
deduce you know where we're all the
people go to party where all the
restaurants where is the financial
district where were the functional zones
of my city how does that break up for
tourism is another obvious application
so where the touristic hotspots how do
people move between those those hot
spots on and you know can we use that
information to improve public services
etc so this is just a different example
I think again from London but so this is
this is looking at a particular I think
a bus line which first ran so this is
the first stop and it it used to run up
to here that's where the bus line would
terminate but then they extended the bus
line two where's the mouse here yeah
they extended the bus line to hear and
so you can it's easier this way so you
can see here this is just a curve of how
many passengers you use the line now you
can say okay we've extended the bus line
from there to there what's the impact on
passenger volume well you could see yes
it's generally gone up me but it hasn't
just gone up here where we they send the
line of course there's an impact which
you can trace back interestingly only
starts from here so the people write the
beginning they don't really seem to be
care about going to right at the end but
you know the people here do and you look
at you can look at the various bus stops
and where the people get off and where
do people get on and has that changed
now we've extended the line and you see
generally that no this is where people
got on before the extension this is what
people
after you see generally more people
going on onto the bus with you know
which you can see by the volume here but
you know you can look at various
patterns and you know so interestingly a
lot of people get off this this top
which is just one stop further than you
know where the previous line ended you
know you could you can look at these
kind of pictures you start your
reasoning and try to think why is this
happening and how can I use this kind of
impatient to to to improve my service so
generally human ability is actually
really it's a really interesting domain
and there's cross-cutting there's cross
cuts with many different fields going
for sociology to epd me ology I computer
science even physics and there's lots of
different lots of interesting work down
here I mean the figure on the left so
this is I think worked on by MIT so you
know if a person visits let's say five
locations you know there's five
factorial ways he could you know visit
those locations many different ways he
could visit those locations but turns
out it's what people actually do they
don't visit you know all the
permutations of these possible locations
uniformly but there's a there's always a
particular sequence people follow when
visiting a certain set of locations so
there's a particular pattern what they
call a motif and you see this motif
appear on different levels so not just
you know the very low level you know I
go to work type thing but also on a high
level how do communities move in things
and how cross large distance but you
know there's patna structure there
that's all really am saying you know and
taking a very high high level view if
you look on the right you know how do
you know how the population groups move
and in this case how how did humans
colonize the polynesian islands in the
Pacific and so you can look you know how
people moved and why they moved and
there's lots of interesting things you
could you could infer there and yeah
just say it's all this is all very
relevant I'm just two weeks ago Yahoo
and Carnegie Mellon announced at a
million pound project to look at how can
we predict human needs and human
intentions with especially focusing on
the spatial sound so that's just some
intro so human mobility so if I don't
know who is here yesterday so Eric dress
the guy who data and art he mentioned
this the you know Hume ability is very
very predictable people are very
predictable the average predictability
for the next hour is ninety-three
percent so if you know where you are
somebody knows where you are now can
guarantee quite to large degree way it
will be in the next hour and the
distance doesn't really have an impact
so it doesn't matter if you are you
traveling ten kilometers or 10,000
kilometers but the pattern is actually
very very regular so there's high degree
of regularity so both spatially as inter
what kind of locations you visit as both
temporally so you know what what you do
in the week there's a pattern there in
the weekend it's different but you know
so you know there's a lot of Prayer
there's a lot of predictability there
and this is just saying the same thing
but just graph some people of published
papers about this and used to find
various plots but you look here this
number of travel activities you make so
for every day in the week you have a
line and so these are all the weekdays
and you see they all you know it'll
pretty much coincide so every you know
the pattern for a whole week is very
regular in the weekend the pattern is
different but still it's extremely
regular I look those two plots
essentially so that show the same thing
so for every day in the week you have a
certain pattern but in the weekend this
one of course things get a bit less
regular because you know you don't go to
work you got visit family go take a
weekend off or whatever so there's a
lots of temporal regularity and in
people's movements a same thing for
spatial so if you look at all the
locations people visit there's actually
only a couple which are really important
than those people visit a lot ie where
you live where you work maybe where your
parents live or depending or you know
maybe you if you know you go to you go
to football club or something but
there's only really a couple locations
with people visit really really often
and there's also a quite a well defined
pattern between those locations and you
can plot those as graphs and the
beginner node the more important
location is and you again you can do
some interesting things however so okay
people are generally very regular and
this has been known for quite a while so
that's good and you can try to learn
those patterns and that's what people
like Google and Facebook etc do so but
the particular work
Hampton was looking at and we
collaborated with was what happens when
people deviate from from that routine so
because that's actually you know that's
actually interesting that's may be
particularly more interesting than the
pattern in itself that when do people
break from these patterns so you know
instead of going to work here you're
you're ill and you you you stay at home
or you you know you decide to take a
weekend break or or something and these
are potentially interesting events and
so tying it back to the technology so
you know being in an unfamiliar place
and unfamiliar time you know would you
think that intuitively though you know
you would help you if you had extra
context where assistance so then if
you're you know thinking about phones
and apps if you somewhere unfamiliar
they're not familiar time you be the
likely a higher demand for needing your
maps or hotels or mobile advertising
could be made more relevant and it's
actually quite ironic I say that now
because yesterday after the the party I
was getting my train back to Southampton
got on the train got into Clapham
Junction but then turned out that
somebody poor soul had been hit by a
train further down the line so
essentially the line was closed and
train wasn't going anywhere so I was
essentially stuck so at that point I was
in a place I've never been before and I
you know I need to say what to do so you
know you pull up your phone and you do
in that case time I you know I really
needed some kind of more information
about k where's a hotel work and I stay
etcetera so these kind of things these
kind of you know breaks in the routine
which are interesting to look at so can
we you know Kelly characterize it is
there a pattern there can we model these
can we predict these let's go so there's
lots of different applications both for
in the learning a person's mobility
pattern but also learning about when
does the person break from this pattern
so going from optimizing public
transport insight into social behavior
how people interact spread of diseases
is a very obvious one recommender system
so again everybody knows about Google
now so you know it tells it tries to
predict where you're going to be in the
next half hour or so and it will give
you traffic information or weather
information whatever so you know that's
exactly what they're doing chirp is
another one context where advertising
obviously law enforcement is
use their urban planning and there's
lots of applications but of course
obviously as Eric right for you mention
yesterday this is you know this is data
about how you move in your patterns and
you know this is there's obvious privacy
& then DM non-elimination concerns there
as well so just you know i he'p made the
point well but just be aware of them so
just a concrete example so so the London
riots so all the red dots where
particular crimes occurred so you know
the rights and they were particularly
crime to be accorded those red dots and
the blue dots are the people who
actually did the crime and the Blue Dog
start out from where these person live
you know so you know who did the crime
you know where they live you know where
the crime occurred and then configure
our okay what's the most likely route
they took from their home place to the
scene of the crime and is there
something you can learn for that so you
know what can we learn about how you
know how people did how they congregated
or what's happening there so this was
that I think dumbo some some company but
the video comes from the quarantine so
this is you know this is something that
I I wasn't involved in so this is just
you know if you look for examples this
is something that the guardian published
an article about that that you have to
ask the police at so you know the
somebody commits some a crime maybe they
catch me on CCTV or something no no this
is sorry yeah this is so this is not not
fiction I mean this is real data from
you know rights happen if you own a
store and somebody Anna knows takes TVs
or something you or the police you
reported they try to find who did it and
and you know that kind of data you can
you can use to these kind of things Oh
oh really okay so well there you go
that's interesting though that you think
that that be an issue okay interesting
right so I mean that that's just an
example of in this case inference so
you're trying to infer from a person
lives to some absinthe and what's the
most likely path there and if you know
you can and that becomes easier if you
know more about that person is regular
pattern etc so we want a model mobility
this is the problem we the work we did
was okay can we look can we pick up
departures from routine somebody has a
particular pattern the deviates from
patent is that it possible to can you
pick that up so that's an interesting
academic from and you know it's this
stuff that Google now and those kind of
absolute use so what what's often done
is you you have some kind of entropy
measure and so this is just a function
and depending on where you are and the
time etc will give you some kind of
number which is how much you you know
what your entropy is how regular you are
but these things kind of breakdown when
you you want to look at higher level
structure and you want to ask more
complex queries so another way of
approaching is is model based so you you
define some kind of model how you expect
people to move and how you expect to
purchase from routine to happen and you
and this gives you more power but it
does build in more assumptions so it
allows you to look at different types of
structure mobility you can incorporate
domain knowledge for example some of
these calendar information you can deal
with trust you can allow for prediction
exception and the work that the James
did was take a complete Beijing approach
so and as a result you're doing you have
a probabilistic model and which will
give you a distribution over some kind
of a path somebody took instead of just
saying look this is the path the person
took no you get a distribution which
says well with high probability you know
this is this is the path you took and
there's different alternatives so if I
maybe should skip over this but you know
it's a probabilistic model which
fundamentally it's always Bayes rule so
I'm sure everybody's familiar with this
so the idea is you you have some set of
unknown parameters
in this case theater and given your data
this is your posterior you're trying to
infer what the most likely values of
those parameters are to match your data
and that's broken down into a likelihood
and a prior but you know I'm sure
everybody's aware of that so just
graphically again so you know you you
have a model with some unknown
parameters and the way it works in
Beijing inferences you first start off
with assuming no prior information about
these parameters so you know could be it
could be anything but as you get more
data your distribution narrows and you
get some kind of peak and that will you
know tell you what you're you're most
likely parameter values are so same
thing so same thing here you always
start with the distribution and as you
get more data and the distribution
narrows and and then you you know
hopefully that gives you a nice narrow
distribution and then you have the right
parameters to to get your result so one
step further then is people well you
know people then create Beijing networks
how many people here are aware of asian
network so know how they work okay
excellence oh every buddy knows how it
works oh that's really good so it just
allows you to factor out your joint
probability distribution into different
components and you can specify the
dependencies between those confidential
variables and you can ask kind of query
so in this case you know we have some
kind of prior knowledge that it's cloudy
or not and then if it's cloudy there's a
certain probably tui the sprinkler will
be on there's a certain probability will
rain and given those two things there's
a certain probability will have the
grass will be wet and then of course the
interesting thing is you know if we we
may not be able to infer these observe
these two things directly we didn't see
it we didn't see it rain or we didn't
see it the sprinklers turn on but we did
do see the grass is wet so then the
question you can ask is okay what's the
most likely cause or another question is
you know given its cloudy what's the
most what's the probability of the glass
is wet and so it's just a probabilistic
model again so then people already know
this so you can then so that's a just a
static static static problem essentially
but you can add time as a dimension and
the canonical example your speech
recognition so you have some kind of
acoustic signal which you sample at a
certain rate so time step 1 x 2 x 3 so
you observe this acoustic signal which
certain properties and from that you try
to infer what the phonemes are which
line up at each time step that's okay
nothing particularly complicated yes so
I mean this is again just intro so it's
a problem is to model so you can run it
forwards I you have a distribution you
can sample that distribution and when
you can run it backwards and you doing
informants and you know you start with
some initial prior as you get data your
distribution will i will update anyway
so so that's just background so in
particular the model what we built so
the idea is we want to model departures
from routine you want to pick up when
somebody departs from routine so what do
you start off with well you the first
assumption you assume that everybody at
every particular time step belongs well
can be assigned some kind of location
some kind of fixed discreet location and
these locations correspond to well you
hope two points of interest so at every
time step you assign somebody a label
okay now is your location one no
location to location three or whatever
so here and so these are discrete latent
variables so we don't know what they are
but these are the things we're trying to
infer then you're going to augment these
so these latent discreet location
variables so this is a time step 1 x 2 x
3 and we say okay so this location well
there's two bits of information where it
depends on so we want to take into
account the time of the day because you
know knowing whether it's midnight or
lunch time or early in the morning you
know that should tell us something about
where that person is we also want to
take into account some kind of periodic
time so think for example the day of the
week so you know where somebody will be
at midnight on Saturday evening is
different than maybe midnight on Monday
evening so we want to take to an account
that kind of temporal information so
time of the day and some kind of
periodic times a day of the week again
you do that for every time step and then
you add in a Markov assumption which
essentially says that where I am at the
particular time time step only depends
on where i was once time step before
where that's what we're assuming so this
is a simplification it makes the
inference and everything much easier and
much quicker but you know there's
nothing inherent stopping you to to make
more complex assumptions that where you
are now depends on where you were maybe
you know 10 time steps away or what you
know these lots of complicate things you
could do but in this case it's just a
simple first order markov property
assumed then you add an extra piece of
information so unless you add another
latent variable which is your departure
from routine which is binary for yes i'm
departing from routine or no i'm
following a perfectly regular schedule
and so this departure value again it
depends on the time of day in the appear
end of the day of the week and you know
it will also give you information also
depend on where you are at what that
location is so you you know you have
this kind of basic structure for every
time step and for every person you have
this model now okay so that just tells
you a bit about you know sequential
structure and about temporal information
but then you still need data so if
you're a user you're walking around your
phone's GPS readings the cell tower
readings you need to fit feed that data
into this model connect it up so you
have sensors and there's different types
of sensors so there's no just noisy
centers for example like cell towers so
they give you a latitude and longitude
okay fine you're here but you know
there's the there's a variance
associated with that so you know it
doesn't doesn't correspond to your exact
location is the location of the tower
and then so you need to infer the
variance and this depends a bit on where
you are so if you're in an urban
environment I hear there's lots of cell
towers around this Lots reading so you
can actually get the quite narrow
distribution over your location because
there's lots of towers around if you're
in a more rural environment like to the
left so location for here you know
there's only one tower there's only one
reading well is a very wide distribution
of way where you could be so that's
something you can infer a different type
sensor is a GPS which gives you a
reported accuracy and
so you know you you get different
readings with different accuracies but
together again they help you narrow down
where your exact location is in the case
if you're looking at for example the the
riot data for example you may have
eyewitness reports where you say okay
somebody saw this person in this
particular street or in this particular
post code or whatever and then so
there's a very wide variance there which
the person who made the average report
eyewitness reports tells you their
variants but there's the issue of trust
you actually believe that is a right was
that accurate is that reliable and so in
this case the variance is given together
with the latitude and longitude but what
you want to infer is the trustworthiness
of that observation and and this is
where the other observation types come
in so if you you know if somebody says
oh I saw this person there but the GPS
recordings or the cell tower readings
you know contradict this the nice thing
about the Beijing approaches you know
you can all integrate that and it's just
that you know even though the person
says I'm very sure but if it contradicts
everything you you know the variance
automatically increases so that's part
of the inference so anyway putting all
the different pieces together what you
get is essentially this this this this
model which is you know repeated for
every time step and every person has
their own as a role model and so it's
the same basic structure so you have
your latent locations these the thing
you're trying to figure out where the
person is at every time step you have
here this departure from routine score
so trying to figure out you know is this
normal well no is this in routine or not
in routine and then you have so your
eyewitness reports your cell tower
information you GPS rep a GPS data these
are just you know examples which were
their associated variances and then
together that bills of the final model
and the details not really important
it's all explained in depth in the paper
if anybody's interested so anyway so
this is fundamentally the problem you
have to solve so you have to find some
kind of distribution over your model
parameters over all the locations you're
you're visiting overall the departure
from routine scores and over the
trustworthiness so these
you're unknowns these are the things you
have to infer given the observation data
and I think these are the variances of
the of the observation data they're
reported so that's the information you
have you apply Bayes rule and you get
some complicated formula but essentially
this is what you have to solve and so
this is the inference problem that any
Beijing method requires and there's many
different ways of tackling this but you
know exact inference unfortunately is
intractable you console that exactly
just for complex models it just doesn't
work so you need to do some more
approximation so there's this and again
this is not really my area but so you
can do eem expectation-maximization
something which is very fast but it only
gives you a point estimate it doesn't
give you a full distribution it just
tells you know this is the most likely
location where you were but it doesn't
give you any kind of distribution over
that location you can do is Monte Carlo
methods where you sample like Gibbs of
Metropolis and they give they do give
you full distributions but the very slow
and you have somewhere you know
somewhere in between variational
approximation which does give you full
distributions and it's quite fast so
that's what was used here again gives
you some advantages and there's a
reference there but if people are
interested I would say just check the
reference so anyway so we've built up
the model we can do inference and that's
nice so that will influence will tell us
about what am i my my most interesting
locations one of my main locations I
visit what's my departure from routine
score at different time steps it can
learn about the noise characteristics of
sensors it can learn about
trustworthiness or which sensors are
which you know in case I reports which
are trustworthy or not and the
parameters you get you get full
distributions but you can interpret
these intuitively way you know you can
express things in terms of belief or
probability and intuitively that's you
know people can understand that and it's
that you can actually wind the model
forward and start to do a bit of
prediction you know where will somebody
be and you know so many steps ahead or
when will somebody depart from routine
given this information so there's some
advantages so you can start looking some
performance data so this was with an
early version of the model
not work i was involved in nokia
released a data set of GPS tracks
various people and you know you can try
to see you can compare different methods
and in this case I believe it was indeed
predicting departure from routine and so
there's different methods the main one
was you know our one came out on top
yeah that's the most important one by
anyway but this is more interesting
really so this looks at on the x-axis
you have an entropy measure so this is
think of it as a you know a departure
from routine score so the higher the the
entropy the more your departing from
routine so the more you're doing
something out of the ordinary and on the
y-axis you get how you know the
probability you're going to use a
certain application on your phone so
this is part of the reason why nokia was
interested in this and indian you see
what you wouldnt to leave expect you
know the more you're in an unfamiliar
situation one and unfamiliar time when
you're doing something out of the
ordinary the more you're going to use
email the more you're going to surf the
web the more you know call people the
more you use messaging app so there's
this there is a definite correlation
there so that's why it's interesting to
look at you know when do people suddenly
depart from routine then so that was
with Nokia data so this is a different
data set so in this case the Nokia data
was all just gps data which was you know
very nice and very easy to work with so
this is looking at he true genius
observations so cell tower eyewitness
gps etc and untrustworthy in trustworthy
observations and the the and we used
there's another data set called the open
paths data set which has mobility traces
people and we use that as well to kind
of build a synthetic data set we can
test against because the big problem
here is if is you want to get hold of
realistic data because you want to
benchmark how well you're doing and
that's actually very hard to get get
hold of I'm so you have to kind of craft
your own that kind of hopefully makes
sense when you can do some performance
on it and see how will it perform so
here it just says the number of days of
observations and here is the the
resolution in distance of how how
finally you can narrow down some of
these location
you see the roughly after i think is
roughly about two weeks or so you can
narrow down somebody's position up to
about 60 meters in a kind of predictive
way and so you know depending on the
application that's usually enough or not
enough but the main thing is the trend
so as you get more days of observation
as you build up more more observation
you learn about somebody's pattern you
can be more accurate in predicting you
know where they're going to go next and
your the distribution over the possible
locations really narrows down so that's
good you want to see that kind of trend
then looking at predicting actually
departures from routine so again we see
as we get more more days of observation
as we get more readings and your your
accuracy so your precision actually goes
up to around seventy percent and then it
plateaus off roughly so after was it two
three three weeks of observations you
can predict some of these departmental
routine you know relatively accuracy and
the recall is actually very good you
know you get you can you know recalls
very high so you capture all the
departures from routine so so that
that's very very good and these were
really state-of-the-art results and
these at once will will hopefully
publish a kiedy deal later this year so
then just to step back so the
implementation is just standard Python
libraries and there's a UI on top which
the purpose is just to understand if the
prediction is the model is making does
it make sense you know whether they
intuitive and you know there's nothing
fancy they're actually just note all the
inference and things was all written in
custom code though there are some
libraries like jensen pi pi nt-based pie
etc which you can use and that's maybe
something to look up to work to do in
the next iteration there's also a lot of
interest in probabilistic programming
these days and you know this there's
something interesting to check out in
future but just to show you visually so
this just shows row observations of a
particular person and in this case
they're all cell tower readings so you
know these are all the readings that
were taken so the question is you know
so you have all these readings but
what's the path the person took how did
we move you know did he go from there
down to there or they go you know this
way or you know well what's what's the
he took and so this this is where then
you run the model on this kind of data
and then you get something like this so
this exact same view and what you see is
then this is the most probable path so
followed so the model predicts say given
all these observations this is actually
I think apart the person took the main
significant locations so the L variables
on the model they are plotted here so
these are the locations the person
spends you know at least a reasonable
amount of time a lot of the observations
disappear and because they because when
you go to the results of the model the
opacity of these observations is
directly proportional to the departure
from routine so all the observations
here which were correlated with just
very routine behavior they disappear and
you're only left with the key
observation so these ones they occurred
in at times when the person who's
actually departing from routine so when
you get some kind of trace and you get
and it's relatively accurate as to where
you know the path a person took there's
only five minutes so I'll just to
illustrate just the inference so this is
a particular very regular pattern so
somebody's I know he's at work and then
he goes home and then well I know he
goes to the gym or something okay that
doesn't really fit but because he
doesn't sleep anyway the only thing that
matters is really have one to three
different locations where this person
transitions through so we first hear
then he goes there then it goes there
and it goes back to the first location
it's a very very regular pattern so this
is just an artificial data set then we
can say okay now look here we have the
same trace only at this time so he's up
here in location six now in usually he
would transition down to location for
but in this case he actually spends you
know a couple of hours longer in
location six before he transitions to a
location for this is an example of a
temporal departure from routine you know
usually he does this but actually for
some reason he's spending more time in a
particular location than we and we used
to seeing him do so and so in the UI you
see that the model picks up on this
so you get some circles and you get you
know you you get a warning they're
saying look you know this is something
out of the ordinary day and so this is a
sanity check because that's exactly what
you want to want to happen so that's an
example anyway maybe skip to the end so
you know this was a very communal a
synthetic example but if you look at
real data things are a lot more complex
and you know it's less intuitive to see
why a person departs for routine but
anyway you can look at compare different
people you know so in this case there's
two people and you know they roughly
depart from a routine at the same time
so you could say you know all their
correlations there or do you know what
just different you know can can you does
that tell some so tell you something
well the social behavior or people kind
of activities people do together
extension and there's lots of other
things you can try to infer from that
anyway last light so summary so this is
just a you know kind of summary of the
the work we did looking predicting
people to purchase from routines or
people very regular pattern but also the
portraits of routine you can capture
quite accurately there's a lot of
limitations though well I mean the main
thing is getting good ground truth data
a realistic data and so you know you'd
need more more data from people who know
each other using weather data there's
lots app data which could be useful and
so something we're working on and
there's lots of more advanced things you
can do and I mean the interest on is for
example a taxi driver so a taxi driver
well his routine is that he has no
routine these going all over the place
of the whole day you know all kinds of
random locations so you know can you
know you can just ignore that say okay
we won't deal with that but still you
know is there something you can learn
for that so you know that's an
interesting question yeah that's it so
any questions about this or references
or whatever
yeah yeah it's possible to know whether
this happened is he can intentionally or
unintentionally yes okay so I mean
that's one of the points right somewhere
I thought it was on there I ok so
there's also you know what ok fine you
can detect when some of these deviating
from his pattern he's going somewhere
where he usually doesn't go too he's
going in in a different order we staying
somewhere longer or shorter than he's
used to so you can pick that up then
questions why you know why is he doing
that and you know we can't answer that
dip here then you need a lot more
context information but for example the
the nice thing about this is this
Beijing model is you can input quite a
lot of domain-specific expertise you can
put in information about persons
calendar about maybe he's hobbies or the
other people he knows and then you can
you can build up a larger picture you
know if you know if you know he he plays
football for example and you know he has
a particular training schedule but then
maybe at some point it's a long distance
well you know he's doing in a way match
or something or all that kind of context
information you could incorporate but
you know that's you know that that's a
rabbit hole of its own but you know that
yeah that's a big problem but you know
you can try work at it yeah go ahead oh
maybe
quantifying this probability happen
Mike relates to this invention vs
yes actually because if I if I remember
correctly ya know these these are
detections and on are quite predictions
so we have looked to predictions and of
course the further you go and head of
time the less reliable it becomes and
there's there's a there's a tail off and
well you you have the full model so you
have the full distribution so you can
you know you'll see the variant spread
spread spread out as you go further
ahead but I wouldn't be able to say give
you exact figures or accuracies on that
boy yeah so I can't really answer that
but up with some more work we should be
somewhat yes our verses you're either
following the routine exactly yes and
that's something I didn't explicitly
mention but yes and you saw and this is
where this is out of my comfort zone
you're asking the wrong person really
for the exact details of how it works
but these are binary variables yes a
person is in departing from routine or
not but until on top of here this is
actually a continuous probability of a
person departing for routine which is
you know which takes into account that
binary by new variable but so the exact
reasons of how this works and how this
is linked together I'm not I can't
really answer but actually if you look
at the final model output you do get a
number between 0 and 1 so it's not a
binary decision the degree of variance
from routine meaning that rather than
going to one pub they might go to one
new bar this is going to one in a
another city across the world yeah no
indeed so
this is some so I I don't know enough
about the underlying model but i'm i'm
quite sure this is something that is if
not already captured that I just can't
explain it properly um but yeah I agree
that's something you should you should
be intuitively able to do so but I can
icon on superficial
so let me think so it's not well I don't
think so if we look at so one example
there were roughly about two weeks worth
of data roughly in 10 10 or 15 minutes
intervals at various sensors and to
train the model on that so two weeks
with data is roughly on a you know
standard desktop PC you talking about on
the order of half an hour to an hour or
so yeah yeah just to train and this
isn't you know this is an offline model
so you know is if something changes
there's you change your trust of some
sensory modality or you if you you know
if you make structural change you have
to retrain everything so I don't think
it's something that you could just run
on your app at this point but a planned
extension of this work is to look at
online method so you can just bit by bit
update the model as the as the data
comes in instead of having to retrain in
a few but so I oh if that answers your
question yeah